la suite de notre feuilleton maintenant
avec une visite exceptionnelle de
l'institut de recherche criminelle de la
gendarmerie et c'est au fort de rosny
près de paris normalement ces enquêteurs
travaillent dans l'ombre mais rien pour
nous ils dévoilent leurs techniques
d'investigation aujourd'hui c'est une
moto qui est au centre de toutes les
attentions
elle a servi à un braquage dans le
garage de l'institut à rosny sous bois
les experts passent à l'action sur la
moto les braqueurs ont peut être laissé
des empreintes des traces d adn
c'est l'espoir de ces deux hommes les
enquêteurs chargés de la faire
si la moto parle leur dossier pourrait
avancer les plaques
on essaie de préserver toutes les traces
qu'on peut trouver à des traces
digitales au maximum et là nous on a
l'opportunité ne l'est peut-être pas
très loin de ronnie donc ça va qu'on
travaille beaucoup les premières
inspections d'ensemble il faut se
répartir le travail entre les experts et
les haines et ceux des emprunts
donc moi si j'ai peur j'ai fait un
iphone il a les poignets
ce sera donc pour le lieutenant
donadille elle prélève l'adn à l'aide
d'un coton tige
la seule chose que je vais pour avoir
puisque à priori ce sont pas blessés en
tout cas on n'a pas d'informations sur
le fait qu'ils aient pu être blessé donc
je peux pas rechercher des traces de
sang et donc du coup on suppose que si
ils ont pas mis de gants le seul support
biologie qu'ils ont pu laisser
éventuellement de la déformation de peau
ou alors de la transpiration
l'adn les empreintes pour identifier un
suspect encore c'est la base de la
police scientifique
le quotidien des experts de l'institut
le capitaine des brosses justement il
ouvre le scellé contenant les mains
inconnues deux épidermes 2 po qu'il va
enfiler comme des gants pour relever les
empreintes et identifier le corps un peu
de poudre noire un morceau de scotch
la méthode est éprouvée en fait une
technique qui a été utilisé au moment de
la thaïlande pour identifier les
personnes au moment du tsunami
mais les personnes ayant séjourné dans
l'eau en fête l'épiderme cdh est
directement alors cette personne si a de
la chance est connu dans le fichier
automatisé empreintes digitales si
jamais ce n'est pas le cas soit les
enquêteurs ont un soupçon d'une personne
qui a disparu parce que la famille est
inquiète et a sont là le but est d'aller
chez elle récupérer des objets
personnels sur lequel nous allons
rechercher les empreintes digitales et
les comparer avec ses empreintes que
nous avons mises en évidence
autour de la moto les experts en
empreintes sont maintenant au travail et
au bout d'une heure
l'espoir renaît près des fils arrachés
par les braqueurs pour démarrer l'engin
on distingue une empreinte et ça ce
n'est pas le maire actuellement chaque
individu est unique grâce à ses
empreintes
il y a bien sûr celle des doigts mais
aussi celle de la paume
on l'appelle l'empreinte palmaire avec
beaucoup de précaution les experts
prélève celles trouvées sur la moto l'
enquête pourrait bien être relancé
il ya plusieurs zones dans la zone dans
la halle dans la paume ça qu'on parle de
palmer et
là mais c'est vraiment à priori ça
serait cette zone là ma main gauche ou à
droite comme à gauche une empreinte qui
servira si un suspect déféré devant la
justice la justice qui soumet une autre
énigme aux gendarmes de l'institut sur
la civière dans ce sac blanc un corps il
a été retrouvé dans un grenier
il y a quelques jours
selon le médecin légiste la mort remonte
à plus de dix ans il ne reste que les
vêtements
le corse est totalement momifié vous
allez pouvoir faire telle analyse sur ce
qu'elle est
ouais je les examens qu'on fait
habituellement un examen dentaire pour
aboutir l'identification éventuellement
pour l'instant les enquêteurs essayent
de retrouver des documents qui
pourraient nous permettre de faire un
avis le gendarme christian de tran et
dentistes légiste il va jouer un rôle
clé pour identifier le corps